I never thought that I would take a
photo of my butthole oh that's your
first
mistake and to say you're right it was a
mistake right but you know you your your
butthole is a
business it is her but business your
butthole is a business you have to
mine's not mine's out in retirement okay
right so it's like it's an old fishing
but hole oh yeah by the lake you know
what I mean he's
relaxing right and it's like you know
catching the fish you know what I mean
you know relaxing MH so you want to take
another photo of my but hole Yeah I'm
just cleaning out yeah but if I was like
say I retired and I was going to hang
out with like my old like butthole
friends like my butthole [__] friends
even if I was retired I'd be like Just
for Old Time sake I'm going to make sure
you know the butthole is like oh so when
you're 80 years old and just in case
just in case you just never know